hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i provide content
for new
and aspiring software engineers and
today we are going over
how to pick a coding language
specifically
your first coding language as a beginner
programmer
and you really just have no idea where
to go when you're picking your coding
language there's
definitely multiple approaches that you
can take
to get to that first language one of the
approaches you can take
is figure out what career you want to
end up in
if you are trying to learn how to code
odds are you're looking to
at some point get paid for your work and
get hired as
a developer as a software engineer and
so
do some research into what career paths
are out there
in this field then when you find a
career path that resonates with you
your personality your experience and
really just what you want to do in the
future
then let that lead you to the coding
language because not all coding
languages
are transferable between careers so i'll
provide you with a few
insights into what coding language you
may choose based on the career you want
to be a front-end developer
your track in terms of coding languages
and frameworks
to know is extremely direct
it is a straight shot road and really
what you need to learn is javascript
learn javascript
paired of course with html and css front
end development deals with
what users see when they are on an app
on a web app
and it deals with how they interact with
the platform and
that interaction piece is where
javascript really heavily comes
in so there's front end if you want to
be a back-end developer
what i really recommend is choosing
either javascript again javascript
or c-sharp or python python is great
because it is
very beginner friendly often dubbed as
the easiest programming language
to know and that is great because it can
just do so so much and actually can
be beneficial throughout so many
different career paths so you really
can't go wrong
c sharp is not as beginner friendly
however
it is very very on demand in terms of
the job market and so
if you can find your way to be a great
c-sharp developer you will not have
troubles finding a job and then
javascript is great if you want to do
full stack development front end and
back-end development
because if you recall that was the
language to learn if you want to be a
front-end developer
well javascript is also great for the
back end
and so if you know you want to do full
stack or you're undecided between front
and back end but you know you want to do
web development
again javascript you really can't go
wrong if you want to instead
go into 2d game development again
javascript comes in here and c sharp
javascript being dubbed a bit easier to
learn than c sharp but again c sharp
being so on demand in terms of the job
market now say you want to be in game
dev but not 2d
you want to be in 3d game development so
really the languages to go for would be
c sharp
or c plus plus it's recommended that if
you want to go this route to actually
start with c
sharp and then glide into c plus plus
because c sharp is harder to learn but c
plus plus is also not for the weak and
so going this direction
of c sharp two c plus plus it will just
provide a better learning curve a much
easier learning
process for you and then number five
data science or machine
learning if you want to do one of these
two things it's very much recommended
that you
go for python which is great because
again it's easy to learn
and so that's just a sneak peek into
what languages you can learn depending
on
the career path you're looking to take
however i'll make sure to add some
articles below
that really goes in depth into all the
career paths
and all the different languages
coinciding with them now say you don't
know
what you want to do and that is okay you
don't know what you want to do but you
know you want
to be a developer of some kind honestly
just pick a language
just pick a language throw a dart at the
wall see where it lands and go from
there
truly truly i'm not i i'm being dead
serious
so pick a language and devote time to it
make sure you devote time to it
because it's very hard to get a sense of
language in just a few days so say
something like
okay i'm going to make sure i devote
myself to python for the next
one to two to three months and then make
decisions
after that this allows you to really
learn the fundamentals of
the language and then after that time
period is over
see and ask yourself okay how did i feel
during this learning process
did i like the language did i not can i
envision myself continuing to use this
on a day-to-day basis at work one day
and let that guide your next decision
and honestly just keep
rinsing and repeating until you feel
that you can see yourself
with this language on a job one day i
had picked python as my very first
language
and nagala it didn't take me long for me
to abandon it
not because i didn't like the language
more because in terms of my
learning it was very hard for me to
stick with it because
i didn't get i didn't understand
when i would use certain things i
understood if statements
and all these different ways to go about
programming python but i just didn't
understand
what i would use it for and how i'd use
it how i would use
these if statements and things like that
and so i was learning how to
program learning how to code but not
understanding how i would be
a developer in this role if that makes
sense and so i ended up actually
switching
to javascript html and css because i
loved that
immediate gratification i got when i
changed something when i changed a color
from red to blue and then
when i made sure that on click this
happened i loved that immediate
gratification
and so that's why i say i didn't choose
like the career
the career chose me just because i
loved learning these things and that
coincided with a career
in web dev but no do not be afraid to
keep on trying different
languages again and again because
there's really no
loss in it even if you see that you
don't resonate well with python
well when you start working or when
you're on the job hunt and you see a job
that says
oh we want a web developer that has a
little bit of experience with python
well now
that is you and so don't see anything as
time wasted or
lost in any way because it really still
carries with you some type of benefit
that you may not
see just yet now let me just say this
because this is something i did not know
for a very long time
there is a difference between a language
and a
framework i made the mistake of jumping
into frameworks not
even knowing that there there was a
difference
right jumping into ruby on rails when i
didn't know any which way what ruby was
like truly truly had no idea and so make
sure you
understand the difference a language is
simply put what is used to write
programs while a framework is
a set of tools used to make development
especially development of
larger applications just a much easier
process
something i've said in the past is is
the difference between long division
and using a calculator you still need to
know long division
but after you know long division it's
okay to start using a calculator
to make mathematical problems and
homework a lot faster
and easy but you still know the
back end process of it and so make sure
that when you're looking at all these
fancy schmancy different things
you make sure they are languages and you
go
with the language first because if you
enter a job only knowing the framework
and not knowing the language behind it
that's going to create some real
problems for you
once you are running into errors and
trying to figure out why something's not
working
meanwhile you never realized what
javascript was and here you are
programming in react so make sure that
you
take the time to identify language
versus framework
if you still are unclear of the
difference between the two
make sure to before picking something up
just google
what is x and x so for me i would have
said hey
what is ruby on rails a language or a
framework and they would have said no
girl ruby is the language at the end of
the day be like nike and just
do it truly truly just do it because
again there is no
loss to be had in that process at the
end of the day you're still
learning you're still growing you're
still developing and so just pick
something up and go from there
if you're now trying to see how best to
go about the learning process i have a
video called the best way to learn to
code which i hope will help you
in that process but if you enjoyed this
video please let me know by liking
subscribing i make two to three of these
a week
and so yeah you would see a lot of these
just coming at you just
trying to help you out trying to give
you the best resources insights and so
thank you so much for watching and i'll
see you all later
bye